we are irredeemably selfish,
this is armchair science.
There is not a single sociological study,
psychological study, that's ever shown that.
Rather, the opposite.
My friend, Daniel Batson, spent a whole life
putting people in the lab in very complex situations.
And of course we are sometimes selfish, and some people more than others.
But he found that systematically, no matter what,
there's a significant number of people
who do behave altruistically, no matter what.
If you see someone deeply wounded, great suffering,
you might just help out of empathic distress --
you can't stand it, so it's better to help than to keep on looking at that person.
So we tested all that, and in the end, he said, clearly people can be altruistic.
So that's good news.
And even further, we should look at the banality of goodness.
Now look at here.
When we come out, we aren't going to say, "That's so nice.
There was no fistfight while this mob was thinking about altruism."
No, that's expected, isn't it?
If there was a fistfight, we would speak of that for months.
So the banality of goodness is something that doesn't attract your attention,
but it exists.
Now, look at this.
So some psychologists said,
when I tell them I run 140 humanitarian projects in the Himalayas
that give me so much joy,
they said, "Oh, I see, you work for the warm glow.
That is not altruistic. You just feel good."
You think this guy, when he jumped in front of the train,
he thought, "I'm going to feel so good when this is over?"
(Laughter)
But that's not the end of it.
They say, well, but when you interviewed him, he said,
"I had no choice. I had to jump, of course."
He has no choice. Automatic behavior. It's neither selfish nor altruistic.
No choice?
Well of course, this guy's not going to think for half an hour,
"Should I give my hand? Not give my hand?"
He does it. There is a choice, but it's obvious, it's immediate.
And then, also, there he had a choice.
(Laughter)
There are people who had choice, like Pastor André Trocmé and his wife,
and the whole village of Le Chambon-sur-Lignon in France.
For the whole Second World War, they saved 3,500 Jews,
gave them shelter, brought them to Switzerland,
against all odds, at the risk of their lives and those of their family.
So altruism does exist.
So what is altruism?
It is the wish: May others be happy and find the cause of happiness.
Now, empathy is the affective resonance or cognitive resonance that tells you,
this person is joyful, this person suffers.
But empathy alone is not sufficient.
If you keep on being confronted with suffering,
you might have empathic distress, burnout,
so you need the greater sphere of loving-kindness.
With Tania Singer at the Max Planck Institute of Leipzig,
we showed that the brain networks for empathy and loving-kindness are different.
Now, that's all well done,
so we got that from evolution, from maternal care, parental love,
but we need to extend that.
It can be extended even to other species.
Now, if we want a more altruistic society, we need two things:
individual change and societal change.
So is individual change possible?
Two thousand years of contemplative study said yes, it is.
Now, 15 years of collaboration with neuroscience and epigenetics
said yes, our brains change when you train in altruism.
So I spent 120 hours in an MRI machine.
This is the first time I went after two and a half hours.
And then the result has been published in many scientific papers.
It shows without ambiguity that there is structural change
and functional change in the brain when you train the altruistic love.
Just to give you an idea:
this is the meditator at rest on the left,
meditator in compassion meditation, you see all the activity,
and then the control group at rest, nothing happened,
in meditation, nothing happened.
They have not been trained.
So do you need 50,000 hours of meditation? No, you don't.
Four weeks, 20 minutes a day, of caring, mindfulness meditation
already brings a structural change in the brain compared to a control group.
That's only 20 minutes a day for four weeks.
Even with preschoolers -- Richard Davidson did that in Madison.
An eight-week program: gratitude, loving- kindness, cooperation, mindful breathing.
You would say, "Oh, they're just preschoolers."
Look after eight weeks,
the pro-social behavior, that's the blue line.
And then comes the ultimate scientific test, the stickers test.
Before, you determine for each child who is their best friend in the class,
their least favorite child, an unknown child, and the sick child,
and they have to give stickers away.
So before the intervention, they give most of it to their best friend.
Four, five years old, 20 minutes three times a week.
After the intervention, no more discrimination:
the same amount of stickers to their best friend and the least favorite child.
That's something we should do in all the schools in the world.
Now where do we go from there?
(Applause)
When the Dalai Lama heard that, he told Richard Davidson,
"You go to 10 schools, 100 schools, the U.N., the whole world."
So now where do we go from there?
Individual change is possible.
Now do we have to wait for an altruistic gene to be in the human race?
That will take 50,000 years, too much for the environment.
Fortunately, there is the evolution of culture.
Cultures, as specialists have shown, change faster than genes.
That's the good news.
Look, attitude towards war has dramatically changed over the years.
So now individual change and cultural change mutually fashion each other,
and yes, we can achieve a more altruistic society.
So where do we go from there?
Myself, I will go back to the East.
Now we treat 100,000 patients a year in our projects.
We have 25,000 kids in school, four percent overhead.
Some people say, "Well, your stuff works in practice,
but does it work in theory?"
There's always positive deviance.
So I will also go back to my hermitage
to find the inner resources to better serve others.
But on the more global level, what can we do?
We need three things.
Enhancing cooperation:
Cooperative learning in the school instead of competitive learning,
Unconditional cooperation within corporations --
there can be some competition between corporations, but not within.
We need sustainable harmony. I love this term.
Not sustainable growth anymore.
Sustainable harmony means now we will reduce inequality.
In the future, we do more with less,
and we continue to grow qualitatively, not quantitatively.
We need caring economics.
The Homo economicus cannot deal with poverty in the midst of plenty,
cannot deal with the problem of the common goods
of the atmosphere, of the oceans.
We need a caring economics.
If you say economics should be compassionate,
they say, "That's not our job."
But if you say they don't care, that looks bad.
We need local commitment, global responsibility.
We need to extend altruism to the other 1.6 million species.
Sentient beings are co-citizens in this world.
and we need to dare altruism.
So, long live the altruistic revolution.
Viva la revolución de altruismo.
(Applause)
Thank you.